[Musik]
jeden schritt geht haben sie hat nur ist
97 jahre alt einmal pro woche wandert er
auf die regel mindestens einmal wenn das
wetter in der vorwoche schlecht war auch
zweimal unterschiede werden wieso denkt
dass ich noch mal dass arbeit nicht
obwohl sie muss kritisch weil ich nicht
gekommen
ja aber ich sehe hier kaum viertel leben
ohne kommt ist nur selbständig und
sicher mit dem kampf wurde nichts
gemacht so wenig wie muss man geliebt
haben um mit 97 noch auf berge steigen
zu können und gibt es ein rezept für
glück und zufriedenheit im auto davon
handelt diese fehlen
[Musik]
haben sie ja - aufstieg um kurz nach
sieben bei der bahnstation groupies
pophits es doch wäre eine dienstwagen
und stoppt sie da getan haben was davon
ist doch ausland
aber nach wie vor
frühstücken
hollywood und kuchen waren ein sehr
cooles wandertage sind lang
er steht um drei uhr in der nacht auf
und fährt mit dem ersten bussen der bahn
aus dem luzernischen emmen brücke nach
vitznau helm übergeht früh los damit er
am abend zeitig wieder zu hause ist den
vor ihm liegen acht stunden aufstieg von
groupies bald nach die kunden eine
strecke die durchschnittliche wanderer
in gut drei stunden bewältigen
also wusste schon dass wir sind nicht
schuld wenn du dich voll auf das
stanserhorn bruchsal haben sind sie
überrascht ob sie stammte wo alba fast
allen fast überall weniger doppelt was
fasziniert sie dermaßen atelier ist dass
sie immer auf kritiker das ganz einfach
bewegt aber unser quartett 5 also ein
nachteil und sehr vorteil nicht die
wahrheit also der nachteil ist der
untere teil ist sehr unterscheiden sich
sehr steil und der und der erste vorteil
zu wenig der zweite vorteil von
exponiert drittens gut wie weg
viertens überall urenkel 50 konto für
jedes kind etwa hätte station sowie
stiegen dass sich andere wertungen und
setzt sich gut die luft das talent und
luft wird ich möchte der ist am 31
philipp wie ich oder haben sie angst
bekommt auf der liege und er selber
kennt jeden stein und jeden hof auf
seiner tour und trifft auch ohne
voranmeldung überall auf offene türen
[Musik]
noch einmal in ihre fragen und der
grafik oder ist nicht obligatorisch aber
viele einziger anspruch also wenn seine
gegner nehmen schon noch nicht kaufen
das macht sie jetzt da das buch hält sie
den diabetes gilt aber nur dann
passierte nachteil dass ich dann haben
sie brauchen genau war nicht nur darüber
zu kommen denn abpresse aber ich wollte
dir einfach prophylaxe strube zocken
ja selbstverständlich aber ich halte
mich dass ich vorne verbucht gar nicht
und ich lasse es notiere sie unterdrückt
und messe 6,4 geschätzt
tabaluga die tabelle gibt es nicht man
selber gemacht und wissenschaft anders
wirkliches problem denn weil ich ja und
ich leiste ungefähr 20 das rechnen also
mal in metern geteilt durch sieht die
sekunde und ganze 19
das gibt leichte gegenwart wie vor ist
das team hat den 20
hansi müller ist chemiker in der
textilindustrie bildete er ein leben
lang lehrlinge aus auch im hohen alter
ist der noch ganz naturwissenschaftler
statt auf moderne energieriegel
vertraute einzig auf traubenzucker als
energielieferant und auch nur dann wenn
sein blutzuckerspiegel es im gebietet
[Musik]
die meisten läufer der biologie aber es
kommt vor dass reiner tisch und passiert
den blick der bin ja lange den wunsch
erzählen vier stunden am tag
jetzt laufen wieder hier bin so hier ist
nicht wie lange er kann und nehme ich
das grand und ich weiß dass männer im
alter in sicht da schenke ich dann fast
rein zu wort dein gott und alles sehr
schnell
nun muss sie haben mich quasi darauf
angewiesen dass man immer aktiv
in der sache ist ja bis vor der
landschaft das ist in dem moment ist
auch erfahren hier locker weg das serie
schranken
warum sie zum über sachen ausdenken
bis hierhin begonnen
das dürfte nach einschätzung suisse ja
ich weiß nicht einmal wie lange das ist
schon auch genau körperliche anstrengung
ist die eine seiner wunderwaffen gegen
den zerfall das vertrauen die segnungen
der chemie und in die apotheke der natur
die anderen
[Musik]
das ist schön dass ich bekam conti
madonnas tamino aus atom und was er
jetzt klug koszalin 100 liegt dass du es
sicher dass ich ging daher noch einmal
analysiert und das da ist posta seien
die listen dort forscht da ist sich das
kleine ist vor ihrem vor ihrem zustand
dass sie es sehen so vor kein einziger
weiß ich ganz genau wie schlechter
verliert dabei dass sie hans jörg müller
sagten sich seien einzelgänger
umso mehr erstaunt mich da seine
wohnsituation im oberen stock seines
einfamilienhauses liegt eine junge
familie aus seiner frau vor acht jahren
krank wurde und sein enkel und dessen
frau zu ihm
seither sind noch drei urenkel teil der
ungewöhnlichen wohngemeinschaft geworden
eine win win situation für alle
beteiligten
[Musik]
wir werden jetzt eine frau niedrig zumal
die automatik dauerte sein abschied weil
sie noch einigermaßen herne und
gleichzeitig verstanden dass man alleine
im haus wieder haben sich mit der zeit
dass das einfach wie viel platz für
verlorene schalter wurden familien
profitieren haben geändert dass seehofer
dies war geht februar ich hoffe ich hier
mit diesem tag also xmb umgekehrt das
alles oft verbringt dann mit dem hus mit
dem wohnen ja das ist ziemlich viele
tolle sachen grafik sind dass wir zum
nächsten
aber wenn sie dann meine ich eine
spezialität wenn sie dies zum beispiel
bei familien die spezialität ist also
sehe ich habe probiert die alpen mit dem
hintergrund normale risse wir immer noch
buch name mit problemen leiden unter und
was ist ein not macht ist ich wüsste die
hass beschriftet wenn sie das nächste
mal club
damit soll es einen moment
eines tages kann ich nicht so jetzt ist
es sieht jetzt komme ich meldet ihre bin
aber so richtig mit natürlich gerade
sofort richtig wohl und bin erster brief
habe ich quasi knapp und dvds forum
geschrieben
es ist so ich muss also sehr wichtig
meine leistung wird und so sehr viel
über volle ziehen und das ist was ich so
bis individuell und also ich muss sagen
ich bin natürlich sehr intellektuell
dixie als der fan aber meine frau ist
das ist
[Musik]
das ganze panorama cs5 politik also das
letzte pilatus brienzer rothorn und dem
stanserhorn sagen wir mal im ersten
drittel vom stamm warm anziehen drei
jahre zu ganz retina kennst du das sind
sie in werke links ziemlich steil
overboard naja so im sattel hat denn da
vorne ist durch songs sind mit rosa ist
rundum zufrieden meinte definierter bis
mit niedlichem ist das eine welle machen
davon nicht machten und auf sache
gemacht sobald gesehen da wo wir andere
was ist das natürlich aber dennoch
studieren was ist wollte gemacht was
wenn sie im auge
aufträge schaltet laufe das war das war
schon schlimm für sie ja oder nein ich
glaube man muss nicht das wählen und
nicht vom - das relais was gott und wenn
ich hatte nicht so war denn gott sind
geschafft hat möglich die eins geschafft
ja also daran zu haben
doch
[Musik]
900 höhenmeter und acht stunden aufstieg
liegen hinter hans gerd müller
für mich gab es dabei meter für meter
tiefere einblicke in die ansichten und
erfahrungen eines zufriedenen alten
menschen auf dem gipfel berührt mich das
hektische treiben dann umso unangenehmer
in herne finde ich in meinem leisen
ärger aber keinen verbündeten
wie findet sie gar truppe nur dass wir
nicht unter druck sie nach all dem
traubenzucker während des aufstiegs
steht kurz vor der heimreise noch eine
kleine belohnung auf herrn müllers immer
gleichem programm
komfort das tor nach amerika wo die
frauen bringen oder nervös
andere länder gibt wenn es dabei sind
als die ur nahm die gestufte trinkt
risiko
wieso nicht
die truppe
nach nun haben die richter
bald war die letzte bahn von ricoh nach
wittnau zeit für mich mut zu fassen für
meine letzte frage
sie sehen die ezb ja dann kreation
maßstab ein wenig will ich habe einfach
nicht leben
und irgendwann tot und ich meine keine
große problem die tour hat sie angst und
bin ich geboren werde ich für mich kein
problem krieg und stärker sie gehandelt
um ihr geld
[Musik]
muss nämlich und weise zusammen